[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank in job
nor as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where two brothers antique
Russians give you dubious advice and
menu all the week's news from both Mars
and AFC Wimbledon we have talked about
death that much lately John how are you
are you too distracted by things that
are not death that you're not thinking
about death as much oh I've been
thinking about death a little bit don't
worry about that but I as this podcast
is is airing my new book turtles all the
way down comes out tomorrow
it comes out October 10th and that's a
bit of a you know it's my first book in
six years it is occupied I would say a
majority of my consciousness over the
last couple of weeks and I would say
essentially all of my consciousness over
the last three to five days so I would
love to think about something other than
turtles all the way down right now I
will say Hank you know this because you
were with me but just before we recorded
this podcast we did our monthly patreon
livestream patreon.com slash dear Hank
and John West I only shill for one of
our products in a 30 second period we
were doing a patreon livestream and
someone came into the livestream and
said hey I'm having a baby today but I
didn't want to miss the livestream just
wanted to check in and say hi to
everybody and upon further investigation
Hank it turns out that this person
Jessica was actually about to have their
first baby mm-hmm
in labor in labor at the hospital laptop
open to our live stream so that was
great because it did for a moment make
me think about something other than
turtles all the way down Jessica we wish
you well and we appreciate you bringing
a new life into this world if you want
to come see us on the book tour that's
beginning tomorrow
bad news is them almost every place is
sold out except for our California dates
which are towards the end of the tour
and Nashville Tennessee so hello
Nashville Tennessee is there are there
any other dates that are not sold out
John I think that's it you can find out
more at turtles all the way down
book.com Hank yeah
can I read you a short poem okay write
this your poem is by Robert Frost it was
sent in by Caroline I don't know if it
was the same Caroline who complained
about people singing songs about her
name but regardless that is a great song
by Neil Diamond all right moving on dust
of snow by Robert Frost the way a crow
shook down on me the dust of snow from a
hemlock tree has given my heart a change
of mood and saved some part of a day I
had rude just a nice little short poem
about having a crow dust some snow on
you thanks crows if you would like to
see a crow putting snow on your shoulder
on tour that's not a thing that exists
but we will be in Seattle for pod con
December 9th and 10th I just feel like
we're pushing stuff a lot I mean I
haven't I haven't heard something so
obviously inserted into a podcast since
you said disco pants last episode all
right let's move on to questions from
our listeners this one comes from
Katherine who writes dear John and Hank
just bought my ticket for your San
Francisco Show on Halloween I'm very
excited oh my god I can't believe there
were still schiller I'm very excited but
I have one burning question should I
wear a Halloween costume I want to be
festive but I don't want to be the only
one dressed up will you both be dressed
up face paint and checkered vans
Katherine checkered vans oh the the the
the shoe the shoes the shoes and the
shoes I was like that's a weird
Halloween costume just paint my face and
get it a checkered fan yes I will be in
costume but I will be in costume in all
of the shows during a portion of the
show ish kind of it's complicated I
think I think there's a 95% chance we
are gonna do that bit during rehearsal
and we're both gonna be like I cut it
this is a horrible mistake I I think
it's a 5% chance I think it's a 95%
chance that I hit it out of the park you
haven't heard my talk yet I'm excited to
see if this bit works but yes Hank will
be
stoom I mean you can't you could hardly
get Hank out of costume I mean so I just
found out that our rehearsal shows have
people at them and I'm actually really
like at first this made me like kind of
upset that I was like no one told me we
were her second front of people but now
I'm excited about it because if it
wasn't me on the stage doing this bit
with nobody in the audience John would
think it was terrible but I need the
audience reaction cuz otherwise
otherwise it's gonna get voted down and
I'm not gonna be able to do the weirdest
idea that I have had so far
I mean listen I think it is a great bit
I just don't know if it's one of those
but like there are so many bits in our
lives Hank that when we talk about them
they are so so funny and then when we
actually execute them we're like oh man
like that was like it turned out to be a
brother thing that turned out to be a
thing that we both liked because we were
raised in the same family I don't think
this is gonna be that bit I agree you
know what it's gonna be great to answer
the question Katherine I will 100% be in
costume on October 31st at our San
Francisco show our Halloween spectacular
I am 100% going to be wearing a
hilarious costume possibly more than one
oh wow that's exciting John I'd like are
we gonna have to like stop at the
costume store on the way to the show
correct
or maybe okay we'll just give us
costumes along the way we'll see who
knows what will happen
and also yes please come to our
Halloween show in costume it's should
everybody be a turtle is that no it
should be all turtles no I think there
should be some turtles but if
everybody's a turtle then it's that's
it's actually a pretty good pretty good
joke if everybody shows up as a ninja
turtle everybody's pretty weird you know
the people at the theater are gonna be
like well this is gonna be a weird night
[Laughter]
convention in town we've done some weird
Halloween shows before but not this one
all right that's good another question
all right this one comes from Brendan
who asks dear Hank and John I'm a
cashier at a nationwide warehouse club
thank you could just say Costco it's a
it could be sale or it could be sam's
club you're right and I need a ruling on
register etiquette when one person has
their items on the conveyor belt and
another person comes up with their
purchases is it the job of the first or
the second person to put the divider up
I cannot recall how many times no one
has done it and I start to ring up the
next person's items and then I get
yelled at you're dubious advice is
appreciated it's Brendan not Brandon
Brenton
I I have a strong opinion about this I
don't know if you do I'd have a pretty
strong opinion as well
you go first when you begin to place
your items on the conveyor belt if there
are items in front of you and you have
not put the divider there you yourself
the person placing the new items on the
conveyor belt I don't want to say that
you're a bad person because lots of
people aren't bad people but do bad
things but you're doing a bad thing yeah
this is like so the person who's
currently checked like it could be I'm
currently checking out which means that
like maybe I'm helping bag or I'm having
a conversation with the cashier I'm
currently interacting with another human
I can't be held responsible for what's
happening on the conveyor that's no
longer my area it's not my conveyor work
I don't yeah you put your stuff up there
yeah you put if the person who's who is
currently checking out puts the the
barrier there that's okay that's a
politeness that's saying oh hey I see
that there's I've noticed another person
come up behind me and I'll put the thing
there you're allowed to but it's not
your responsibility in it and if you
don't do that why wouldn't you do that
are you like afraid that the things
gonna bite you it's not made of swords
it's just a little piece of plastic it'd
be cool if it were made of swords I
would make it a high stakes game then I
would love every trip to Costco because
if you like who's gonna put the divider
there and I'd be like not me it's made
of swords the great staredown game I
have the one person whose job it
definitely isn't in my opinion is yours
so the next time you get yelled at now I
know that the customer's always right
and everything but the next time you get
yelled at just remember in your heart
that we know that the person who's
yelling at you is wrong
absolutely also did you know that
Turtles all the way down is going to be
available at both Costco and Sam's Club
that is very exciting news pod calm calm
December 9th and 10th oh god were
unbearable we don't have a real sponsor
this episode so we're crushing it self
promo yeah
oh god speaking of which this next
question comes from grace it writes Dear
John and Hank my sister and I both paid
for John's book when we ordered it as
the date when it arrives grows nearer we
have started to debate about who should
get to read it first she says that she
should get wait I started this question
thinking that they both ordered a copy
but it turns out that they go halfsies
on one copy okay she says that she
should get to read it first and she is
older and I say that I should get to
read it first because she got to read
The Fault in Our Stars first who should
get to read this book first we are both
really excited amazing comma grace ah
good one can you just like read over
each other's shoulders and be like okay
I'm done with the page you turn I'll
turn you turn I'll turn that'd be cute
it's cute but it's not like the ideal
situation for reading a book I feel like
this is up to me I feel like I get to
make the call here oh well that's
terrible news for the younger sibling
grace I've got good news and bad news
the bad news is that you're always going
to be in the shadow of your older
sibling for the rest of your life and
nothing you ever do will be as cool as
your older sibling good oh good good
brother podcasting times continue the
good news is that you get to read
Turtles all the way down first take it
all right
John's made the call made the call on
the pod before the book comes out it's
arriving and grace read quickly be a
kind and thoughtful younger sibling but
yeah that is it I'm the older I'm the
oldest is not a good reason and if she
read tiffey us first absolutely you
gotta do it you gotta got a trade back
and forth good that's right yeah but
then the older sibling gets to read an
absolutely remarkable thing first I'm
sorry we just hadn't mentioned that you
also have
but coming up I realized that there was
it's it's not even a product we can
really promo yet since it's not right
right pre-order but there's nothing
wrong with a little pre promo promo yeah
you gotta gotta get excitement going
also pizza' mess is coming up John
youtube.com / vlogbrothers we'll be
making a video every single day for two
weeks every weekday while we're on tour
for some of it and selling really truly
remarkable Pizza John products I will
not lie I just saw one of them that we
got and it made me giggle like a little
tiny boy I giggled like a baby getting
tickled on his neck it was great
I can't wait for everyone to find out
about it alright let's answer another
question from our listeners this one
comes from E who writes Dear John and
Hank I'm about to start University and
move out for the first time I'm really
excited but I recently found out that my
room is gonna be very small thank God
I'm only 5 foot 1 I don't want to let
this spoil my first year so I was
wondering if either of you guys have
tips advice or experience for living in
a very small room thanks E oh you gotta
watch the house hunters tiny houses tiny
house hunters International or whatever
it's called and you'll be like oh look
it's so great people are paying extra to
live in tiny places now it's the hip
cool thing III think a tiny house is a
great idea so Hank I actually have some
life experience on this subject because
as you may know I lived for two years in
a walk-in closet in Chicago it was a
three bedroom apartment and I had three
roommates and my buddies and I drew
straws in a competition that I still
believe was not completely speaking fair
and I got the short straw and I lived in
a walk-in closet with no window for for
two years and here is my advice first
off you've got a you gotta use the
height of your room so if you've got
like an 8 foot ceiling you've got to
remember it's not just that like 8 feet
by 4 feet that you have to sleep on you
essentially have like five levels of 8
feet by 4 feet so in a way I'm not a
mathematician but it's like a 32 foot by
20 foot room it's just broken up into
five different levels and so wisely yeah
I actually I still
sometimes like to sleep underneath my
clothes and just look up at them there's
something kind of comforting about it
like just like you know like pile your
laundry on your body well I just mean
like I'll just like go lie down in the I
mean this is a little weird but
sometimes when I feel really overwhelmed
by the amount of stimulus that's coming
into my life which I have a little bit
just type in the last few weeks
sometimes I just go into my closet and I
just put my pillow down there and I just
look up at my clothes and I just take
some deep breaths and I think you know
this is probably the safest room in your
house right now I mean I would say that
you're the weirdest man on earth but I
also feel very very good inside of a
closet and well ever since I was a kid
would close myself in the closet
sometimes I do not know I did not know
that you do that and I would not have
admitted admitted out loud that I did
that unless you had done it first but I
do occasionally like to just lay down
inside of a closet alright there we go
and have since I built I built like a
place like a separate closet in my
closet that I would go in when I was a
child and it was not a big closet
no I remember your childhood cause it
was actually quite small yeah I built it
out of omegle I built a closet in my
closet and I would go oh my god Oh Magel
holy snood you just took me all the way
back oh my god
Oh Magel nobody nobody I mean this talk
about a podcast that is not going to
interest anyone other than us everybody
thinks that omegle is an app where you
talk to weird strangers but no roam a
goal was a thing it was a physical thing
that you use to create physical goods
mm-hmm yeah yeah and I cannot I cannot
find it on the Internet yes we have to
find a picture of it to show people on
the patreon because omegle is what's it
called omegle I think so there it is Oh
Mako bagels
oh and may goes the build anything toy
oh my god goals there may be if I'd have
an Omega it'll be better than Omega nope
there's one there's that there's that
with omegle x' with an a Oh we racks the
bills we used to build we used to build
like cars together that you could
actually ride on do they not make omegas
anymore I mean I'll tell you one thing
they're about to because I am about to
apply all of my available resources to
the resuscitation of Omega 'ls I'll tell
you what they do not you can buy old
dirty gross looking omegle pieces on
eBay but not not available in its
original form I mean for a little bit of
context about how awesome omegas are
there is a lot of 162 Omega pieces
available on eBay right now and I would
like to describe the the it's for sale
for 230 dollars and I would like to
share with you the description 106
pieces used an incomplete most pieces
have evidence of usage and it's still
$230 and also I'm about to buy it
I don't know John why don't we just buy
the Omegas brand
Hank Hank what Hank what we'd have to
get out of all of these stupid
businesses that we've been in that have
been taken up so much of our times just
try to try to sell weird tickets to
weird shows salad book why t-shirts why
we could bounce conference why do we
sell items every November with my face
on them with a mustache that says pizza
below them when we could be in the
Omegas business oh my god I cannot
believe that I forgot about omegas until
just now I haven't felt this way Hank
since I was 7 years old
we have to buy we have to buy omegle x'
we have to build them we have to bring
them back well I don't know who owns
omegas John but honestly it can't be
that cot it can't be that patented it's
just tubes it can't be that patented I
mean one thing that might hurt our
ability to defend ourselves in a
trademark litigation of the future is
when we say like oh no we just thought
we were building our own
joy and people could be that the Omegas
people can be like I'd like to point you
to the podcast where you screamed loudly
Hank we have to drop everything and
start building omegle x' I think it's
owned by Hasbro John which is not great
not a great outcome oh no I got a buddy
there
oh yeah no but I do have I do have a
Twitter and I've got a verified account
and I'm adding a Hasbro right now at
Hasbro hey guys
I wanna be your the omegle ambassador
all I need is a vagrant omegle situation
I would like to bring back Omega 'ls
we'll do whatever necessary within
reason weirdos okay are you at 80
characters yep because that was long I
don't I don't have 280 characters yet
but I did just tweet Hasbro hey guys
what's with the current omegle situation
I would like to bring back Omega 'ls
we'll do whatever necessary I decided to
cut them within reason part because
actually I will do whatever is necessary
I know my enemies are gonna say this is
a fool's errand but you have never
played with omegas omegas are amazing oh
yeah no man I don't know kids today kids
these days they got minecraft they're
just building stuff in the in the in the
ether space now but Hank remember you
could build a chair and then you could
build a desk on which you could do your
actual homework that's true I mean why
would you why'd you have any furniture
at all
it was minecraft but IRL you don't think
you don't think kids these days want
real-life minecraft of course they do
oh my god are there advertisements for
omegas on YouTube because I want to
watch them oh you know what we're
canceling the podcast and Hank and I are
just gonna watch you know like my kids
are always watching unboxing toy
unboxing videos which I could totally
don't get except now suddenly I do get
it because I realize that I could maybe
watching omegle x' oh boy actually when
you google omegle x' all you get is
really upset oh there's one there's one
there's one
I found an Omega less video Hank yeah
yep I'm watching watching
oh we're watching it together oh this is
it's funny
this is not good this is not a good
YouTube video this is a very bad video
well about this video is that it is
obviously as excited about of Makos as
we are what I dislike about the video is
literally everything else all right John
you want to answer another question or
do you just want to go oh miggles all
day well the answer to your question
heck is that I want to keep talking
about omegle x' but I recognize that
since we are the only two people
listening to this podcast who know what
omegas are that we should perhaps move
on
maybe maybe what was the question Oh was
there a question it was about well there
was it this question comes from Julia
who writes Dear John and Hank about
three months ago I started to think
about studying abroad in England I would
really really love to do it and no
wonder Julia because it is your best
opportunity to see AFC Wimbledon live in
person but my question is how do I ask
my parents without it sounding like I
hate you and don't want to see you for
the next few months oh and please pay a
lot of money for that only death is free
Julia oh my goodness gracious
not even true death is actually very
expensive yeah well also there are there
are some free things are there Hank I
mean err we don't technically pay for it
mmm in a capitalistic economy anything
can be valued Oh certainly it can be
valued but it's it is currently free
John yes people go overseas and it's a
valuable experience and parents want
their children to have valuable
experiences and that is the first
PowerPoint slide in your PowerPoint
presentation you're gonna go to England
for a month or if that audio of Hank
introducing this idea
hello Julia's parents it's me John Green
did you know that England is a wonderful
country full of educational
opportunities mm-hmm
you can put that part in you can just
cut that mm-hmm
and put it over and over again it's
scientifically proven to make people
more susceptible to spending money and
losing their children I mean it's not
really losing your children right three
months apart I think that the way you
presented
is as an opportunity and probably your
parents understand that as you get older
they will probably see somewhat less of
you and you just need to like get them
used to that idea anyway uh-huh
I agree Hank I have to ask you another
question it's extremely important okay
I don't know if you know the answer to
this because you didn't highlight it in
the questions and I don't know why
because it's obviously so incredibly
important okay it's custom comes from
Kelly who writes Dear John and Hank I
just walked into the hall of my
apartment building and someone is baking
what I believe to be cranberry bread
ready shy and I don't know any of my
neighbors but I haven't had breakfast an
amount of eggs you see my problem my
question is how do I get in on this
hungry belly Kelly which is great
because it runs but that's also how
she's feeling so I mean I you just gonna
like sniff door cracks until you find
the one where the Koran break bread is
coming from and that's a good strategy
too because then if somebody happens to
be walking out of their hallway that's
your that's their first impression of
you and that's a good first impression
and you could be like you know what you
do in that situation somebody opens the
door and they're like oh hello and you
say do you smell crab and then suddenly
you're gonna have a teammate and you
guys are gonna be sniffing doors off
down the hallway yeah and then it's less
weird when you knock and you're like I
mean it just smelled so delicious it
wasn't just me multiple neighbors yeah
yeah Julie over here from across the
hallway I'm assuming that this all takes
place in the friends universe Joey over
here from across the hallway I also
smelled the cranberry bread and now here
we are Phoebe it's nice to meet you
that's actually how your sitcom starts
yeah years and years and y'all gonna get
millions of dollars an episode now I
think it actually was only 1 million
dollars per episode was a simpler time
1990 dollars though which are now way
worth way more Hank
well can you answer the question just
because while you're talking it's gonna
give me an opportunity to scroll further
through the Google Image results for
Omega
which is making me happier than I've
ever felt in my entire life well I mean
I could go back and actually answer a
question about how to live in a small
space because we didn't answer that one
at all we got really stuck on omegle x'
which is i've not found there to be a
huge correlation between amount of space
and quality of life once you exceed a
certain minimum amount of you could fit
your bed and stuff in a space especially
if you don't have a roommate which you
didn't mention having a roommate which
is this like well that is amazing
so it got space to yourself is better
than having a lot of shared space even
if it's a small amount in my opinion
because roommates can smell that
how are those omegas doing John amazing
I'm on the omegle x' has a Pinterest
interest group and there's 34 of us I
would say because I have just joined and
I'm just scrolling through all the Omega
pins wondering how I didn't remember
Omega 'ls until just now what is it with
human brains Hank that something that I
obviously care starting right now more
about than I care about literally
anything else except for my family but I
had forgotten until you mentioned it 12
minutes ago I don't know man I also was
sort of surprised that I was able to
just call the word omegas out of my
brain
after having pictured this thing that I
built with the yellow tubes and the
popping plastic things that made the one
that remember it had wheels it had like
those popping tires so you can turn like
you would have a chair and then suddenly
you would have a chair that could go
places John speaking a little bit of
this conversation do you remember how
maybe two episodes ago we found that
there was a women's store in the middle
of like in the t-shirt women's women's
clothing bins in Arkansas yeah women's
clothing everybody remembers women's
clothing well I recently went back to
women's clothing and found that that
dear Hank and John fans have left
over seventy seven reviews women's
clothing in the middle of a field oh
they're all pretty good so I just
remembered that because we were talking
about things that we had forgotten oh
that's gold
that's gold hank is speaking of gold let
me ask you another question from our
listeners all right this question comes
from Madison who writes to your children
Hank I didn't celebrate Halloween
growing up because of my family's
religious beliefs Madison have you
considered celebrating Halloween with us
in San Francisco San Francisco now that
I'm older my friends who love Halloween
are insisting that I go to their parties
this year because they think I've been
deprived of a tremendous joy and I must
experience it
but I'm confused is Halloween not mostly
a holiday for children if not how do
adults celebrate it are these parties
going to be based around a nostalgia for
Halloween that I don't have is it even
possible to love Halloween as an adult
without having loved it as a child
parties and pumpkins Madison I think
that it's interesting I had never
thought of it that way but yeah I think
that there is a certain component of
nostalgia for the fun that we had as
children and Halloween but I think
that's a pretty small part of it it is I
mean to be totally just Frank and open
it's just an excuse to party and have
have a party and dress up in weird
clothes and drink well but not everybody
drinks at Halloween parties I assume
yeah it's mostly an excuse I think to
dress up and and to you know wear a
costume and to try on you know living a
life vastly different from yours for a
few hours which is something that is fun
in childhood but can also be fun in
adulthood so I think maybe that's the
attraction of it I I was never that into
the spooky aspects of Halloween I have
always been a person who felt that real
life was plenty frightening without the
introduction of unnecessary skeletons
etc but I did always like the dressing
up part of Halloween there like being
someone else part I wasn't listening to
what you were saying at all John because
one I'm terrible at podcasting and two I
was reading Adam MacLaine's review of
women's clothing store and the
Center of Arkansas he says being a
person that does prefer the fit of men's
clothes I was really here because of the
recommendation from dear Hank and John
I'm also from the future where we didn't
make it to Mars in time while I will
agree with other reviews that the
infrastructure that could be improved
and would be welcome for accessibility
I'm pretty sure this site is not ad a
compliant I also agree with others that
it is very eco friendly and locally
sourced fabrics are a pleasant find
there it seems to be minimal negative
environmental impact from this
establishment and it may in fact have a
net positive impact we need more
businesses like this dftba
while we're reading responses from past
episodes Hank I have to read you this
response we've got from Oh Maya you may
remember that in a previous episode of
dear Hank and John we discussed a
researcher who stuck himself with bees
all over his body to find out what is
the most painful part of the body to be
stung by a bee we on and Oh Maya wrote
in to say Dear John and Hank I am
listening to your most recent podcast
and you talked about Michael Smith the
Cornell graduate student who stung
himself with a bee multiple times for
science and I know him I was an officer
in the Cornell beekeeping Club for
several semesters and he is the graduate
student advisor for the club so we met
several times I can attest that his name
is Michael Smith and that he is quite a
character and that if you met him you
would no longer be confused about why he
would do such a thing for science he is
very committed to bees don't worry be
happy
Oh Maya with a bee with two E's or AV
happy good well I'm glad that that was
real and as a real person it's not that
big of a world John it isn't that big of
a world speaking of how small the world
is Hank I want to ask you a question
from Ariana before we get to the news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon Dear John
and Hank last year I made a very good
new friend who has been nothing but kind
to me on my birthday she went out of her
way to get me multiple gifts and
welcomed me at my new school although I
know she has told me when her birthday
is all I remember is that it is maybe in
January or February I would really like
to get her something but I don't know
how to find out when
her birthday is without hurting her
feelings in desperate need of a name
specific sign off Ariana I mean I feel
like like first of all you can't you
just look at our Facebook page it's not
a thing listen to some people don't know
young people don't use Facebook Hank
okay well when we were kids only young
people used Facebook well the kids I'd
be 30 okay now no young people use
Facebook so which is from my perspective
you say hey what's your birthday
is that weird are you so yeah you can't
no of course I can't do that you know
like but you're not like born knowing
what everybody's birthday is was there
she says in the question that she told
me her birthday and I forgot it once
he's once you've been told someone your
birthday once if you forget it
that's on you forever there's no coming
back from that everybody knows that
sorry okay Ariana you have to move again
I'm sorry
ha I know that you just got used to this
new school and it's great that you've
got this great friend but it's over I
mean I feel like there are so many
people in the world who know this
person's birthday like ask their mom be
like hey what's the birthday that's a
brilliant idea
that is a brilliant idea I just yeah I
was gonna say call the home phone but of
course that's not an option
that's even more anachronistic than a
high school student with a Facebook I
mean I'm like what a sweet thing till I
get a get one of your friend one of your
child's friends to copy you and say hey
what's the I just wanted to know cuz I
like your child so much you want to
celebrate her birthday yeah Ariana Hank
is right it is not bad to just ask but
obviously it won't be as much fun if you
just ask so we need to think of a way
that you can figure it out without
asking you got to find her birth
certificate innards house I like Hanks
suggestion that you should burgle your
friend's home it's bold its innovative
but I think it's wrong I think the right
solution is that you should hack into
their computer oh no just the NSA
database Oh
idea yeah call ed Snowden get into that
NSA database and they'll just be like so
what do you need do you need records of
all the calls you've ever made and
you'll say no no I don't thank you
though all I need is my best friend's
birthday
[Music]
by the way I Kris and I have been best
friends for many many years I I could
not tell you if Chris's birthday is I
couldn't tell you a season could could
you somehow get them to reveal it
without asking could you feel like Oh
what was your last birthday like oh yeah
was it a windy day yeah my birth it
rained what was the top single on the
chart was it Demi Lovato
or was it ariana grande because I could
never tell my still heart do you
remember when McDonald's red out of
tomatoes for three weeks was that during
your birthday try to have here at
McDonald's birthday fun but uh but it
will you would see was all ruined by the
tomato shortage yeah are in closing
Ariana asked ask your friend oh and get
her Omega 'ls for her birthday
Omega Liz available soon at John and
Hank brought back omegas calm you can
also go to Hank and John brought back
omegas calm but that website isn't as
good right it fulfills many of the same
purposes but it has much better design
that reminds me that today's podcast is
brought to you by Omega --ls Omega 'ls a
real toy that Hank and I played with
endlessly throughout our childhood that
I had forgotten about until half an hour
ago this podcast is additionally brought
to you by sniffing door cracks God sniff
out those door cracks to see where that
cranberry bread is that was weird
that was weird part of me wants to go
back in time to win before I heard it
and just lived in that place for the
rest of my life I apologize and
additionally today's podcast is brought
to you by Turtles all the way down
Turtles all the way down available in
bookstores everywhere starting tomorrow
also Costco and Sam's Club and finally
this podcast is brought to you by amaze
amazes not at all in any way inspired by
or related to omegle x' John and Hanks
new product in case Hasbro does not have
an interest in this amazes amazes
available at well I guess there's no
more toys are us only on Amazon it's an
Amazon exclusive and how is amazes calm
available oh god is it hold on
run don't walk to amazes calm it is 100%
available haha I'm getting it's
happening it we are bringing back omegas
we're calling them amazes and I am ready
to go to court with Hasbro yes yeah wait
hold on let me see if let me see if
they've replied to me nobody replied to
you John you don't know that Hank I have
a very important Twitter you know people
notice when I tweet them no they have
not replied to me there's one like on
that tweet John and it's me hold on let
me go to my analytics well that tweet
just so you know it's had 200
impressions Hank and nobody liked it I'm
just one of them liked it and to be fair
if you haven't heard the episode it's a
little bit of a weird tweet also if you
have heard the episode Hank before we
get to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon I want to share one fact with
you mm-hmm
do you know what that fact is no sir it
is a name it is a name specific sign-off
from Natalie okay she has two one is you
have a great person a tallit person
Natalie it's really good great person at
elite I mean and I wish that I could go
back in time and rename my kids Natalie
alt both of them and she also has one
that is based off the Bruno Mars song
Natalie I ran away with all of Bruno
Mars's money comma Natalie I don't
understand that one because over the
sofa all right Hank what is the news
from
this week oh wait should I do the news
from AFC Wimbledon first it's so
incredibly exciting well do it ma'am
Hank Hank Hank what if I told you that
mom and dad our mom and dad went to an
AFC wimbledon game at Kings meadow on
September 30th oh that's wonderful
they had an awesome time and do you know
how AFC Wimbledon celebrated the arrival
of my parents at the Wimbledon game with
girls what is the other possibility with
no goal that is the one you gotta take
on the second try no AFC Wimbledon did
not score in that game against Rock Dale
Roach Dale Roach Dale rosianna is not
here okay so I'm not gonna get an answer
on that one yeah they did not score
which I don't know if you know it's been
a bit of a theme there hasn't been a ton
of scoring AFC wimbledon have now played
11 games in their league 1 campaign and
they have scored 5 goals which I'm not a
mathematician but that seems to be less
than one goal per game and in fact less
than one goal per every other game I am
sorry it's not going great we slipped to
21st in the table which is in the
dreaded relegation zone the bottom four
teams in Ligue 1 are demoted down to
Ligue 2 which is the bottom rung of
full-time professional football in
England and that is not where we want to
be we want to be in League One the third
tier of English football where all the
cool teams are like Doncaster and Oldham
and Peterborough it's a very difficult
situation right now
Neil Ardley is concerned I keep looking
at his face on the sidelines when I
watch the games on my phone and I see
the the face of a concerned person and I
share his concern and I am ha I'm
worried and I don't know what to do and
I feel a little bit I don't know what I
don't know what to do all right what is
the news from Mars the news from our I
mean there's so much news from Mars this
week John but I think the obvious thing
that we have to talk about is Elon
Musk's very ambitious plan to send too
large
loads to Mars by 2022 followed by
payloads of human passengers by 2024
which I will remind you is way before
2027 also way before we could ever
possibly do that
like I could imagine a world in which a
rocket could get there in that fast
maybe but to build all the things that
would need to go in the rocket for the
humans to get there and survive that
seems a little outlandish but 2024 is
like three years before 2027 and four
years before 2028 so I don't know we got
hey we got lots of opportunities so the
news is basically that Elon Musk's
company SpaceX was working and is still
working on a rocket called the I think
the Falcon Heavy which would be one of
the biggest Rockets ever but it turns
out that it's very hard to build a big
rocket and they thought that they could
just sort of strap some extra things on
top of their existing platform and that
would be that the new awesome rocket but
it's not that simple so they want to
build a new kind of rocket no one that
is still based on one booster that will
push a payload up and then return back
to earth and land and be able to be
reused regularly and what that would
allow for is getting not just one of
these one of these payloads a very large
payload 150 tons I think is the max up
into orbit but then they could shoot up
another one that would just be full of
fuel and that could refuel the entire
payload that got into low-earth orbit
and that would allow that because
getting from orbit to like the hard part
is really getting out of like the
atmosphere and out of Earth's gravity
well a little bit so that would allow
for that rocket to get much farther with
just one refuel or with several refuels
to get to mars which is a really smart
and interesting way to do it so to allow
for a refuel rocket but then all of
those boosters all of the really
expensive parts are all coming back down
to earth to be reused again and this is
Ilan's plan for how do you make this
something that happens economically
because it turns out the fuel is a
relatively minor part of the cost the
that engines themselves which we have
previously just been crashing into the
ocean and not reusing are they are the
costly part and he wants to make a
really really big rocket called the BF R
stands for big f and rocket apparently
is my guess and it was not discussed and
and used the BF r to expand humanity's
spaceflight capabilities dramatically by
2024 which John would maintain the name
of this podcast come hell or high water
dear Hank and John so I just want to
confirm real quick what you just told me
which is that Elon Musk announced that
he the way that he thought he could get
to Mars isn't gonna work so instead
they're gonna do a totally different way
but it's also going to take less time
correct John it's all about innovation
and hard work okay well I I am so
excited for Dear John and Hank coming to
a podcast near you in 2028
all right well we'll see what happens
John it doesn't matter as long as we're
working hard on a Maysles by then I mean
the truth is I think we both know we're
gonna be out of the podcasting game
entirely because we're gonna be running
our amazes Empire John what did we learn
today well I mean the most important
thing we learned by far is about omegle
right we also learned that apparently
there's something I did genetic or
habitual that it makes both John and
Hank really like to be in closets alone
we learned that John and Hank will both
be wearing costumes on October 31st at
the turtles tour in San Francisco Hank
what was your phrase the week can I
guess you can guess
was it mmm-hmm because you said that
like 12 times
ah no apparently that's just a new
verbal tic I have okay what was it it
was come hell or high water oh man I
should have gotten that alright what was
mine it's not gonna in a right at the
end
I'm guessing got the short straw no no
it was not although it could have been
it was fool's errand and I snuck it in
right at the beginning I shouldn't I
shouldn't caught that yeah yeah well
there you go Hank and I are getting
better at this game so much better than
that you know almost impossible to catch
us at this point yeah alright stop
paying fun we're gonna have to we're
gonna have to pick some harder phrases I
Hank thank you for potting with me
thanks everybody for listening you can
email us at Hank and John at gmail.com
or find us on Twitter where I am John
Green Hank is Hank green you can also
find us on patreon patreon comm slash
dear Hank and John we're gonna go record
our patreon exclusive podcast this
weekend Ryan's right now but in the
meantime thanks again for listening and
for all of your wonderful questions this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
all rights produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson our ahead of
community and communications is viktoria
bon giorno who keeps making fun of me
for getting her title wrong so i did it
right this time
and our theme music is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
you
[Music]